tous les jours une femme décède victime
de violences conjugale en France afin de
mieux protéger et sécuriser ses femmes
le parquet général la préfecture la
région et le département de La Réunion
signe cette convention pour la mise en
place du dispositif téléphone grave
danger les femmes en situation de grande
détresse disposeront d'un téléphone
portable équipé d'une fonction spéciale
d'appel d'urgence
d'écoute avec Mondial Assistance des
écoutants qui seront sont formés à cette
situation et qui vont tous tout de suite
en fait lui poser les bonnes questions
pour lever le doute est-ce un vrai appel
ou un appel de détresse s'il y a
vraiment danger et que c'est un vrai
appel du coup intervention de la police
et des forces de l'ordre sur
interpellation de la plateforme c'est à
dire qu'en fait la dame elle sera tout
de suite
identifiée on saura où elle est par des
repères GPS et on pourra savoir
immédiatement
où elle se situe au moment de son appel
grâce à son téléphone et ce qui
facilitera l'intervention des forces de
l'ordre 15 téléphones portables seront
mis en service à la Réunion le réseau
vif accompagne ce dispositif et
particulièrement dans la prise en charge
globale des violences intrafamiliales et
pendant les six mois à un an où elle
aura ce téléphone à sa disposition
notez cette femme victime voire dans
quel état psychologique victimologique
et sociale elle se trouve de façon à
faire évoluer sa situation pour qu'on
aille vers une sortie du dispositif le
département de La Réunion agit au
quotidien pour aider les femmes victimes
de violence notamment grâce à des
assistantes sociales détachées au sein
des commissariats et des gendarmeries
sur toute l'île on est en première ligne
au niveau des victimes de violence qui
viennent au niveau des gendarmeries ou
au niveau des commissariats on essaye
effectivement d'être à leur écoute et de
pouvoir les accompagner tout au long de
leur procédure pénale et tout au long
effectivement de la reconstruction je
pense que c'est une avancée
significative puisque aujourd'hui avec
le téléphone grave danger de façon
concrète la femme victime de violence
elle pourra interpeller de façon très
vite les forces de police et avoir un
accompagnement adapté à sa problématique
jusqu'à maintenant on avait de de
l'accompagnement une mise à l'abri et
aujourd'hui soit des situations plus
complexes c'est la possibilité pour la
femme et pour les enfants de faire
intervenir très vite les forces de
police le dispositif téléphone grave
danger pourra sauver des vies et
particulièrement à la Réunion où les
violences envers les femmes sont
fréquentes en 2013 près de 1700 plaintes
ont été déposés pour violence soit près
de 5 plaintes par jour